- [ __ ] you're just living it up do
this well single and just going about
traveling the [ __ ] world
they're not for five years okay I've
been running a [ __ ] company giving my
life to them first so I cut out my white
anchor just [ __ ] yep it's [ __ ]
been the best it's interesting though I
think like some people when they take
their breakups like some people take it
very poorly but some people take it in
stride like some people we know yeah
home and [ __ ] cry like a little bit
all day it's like I think for you like
you've been you've always been able to
like car compartmentalize your feelings
at what's going on it's like okay and
and it's not like for you when you when
you broke up with her it happened
overnight that was a process that was a
step to it and then yeah we lived
together for like almost two months
after the breakup and and we cried
together we were there for each other we
were able to like ease out of the pain
you know yeah and I think I was just
ready to [ __ ] be in charge of just
myself I think you've been ready for a
while man I think like even though for
you you can you you have this ability to
to cut out [ __ ] really well but you
do have a really big heart so it's still
very hard if there's like this there's
this want of you know what you want to
do but it's you're also somebody else
who just you're not gonna watch somebody
drown in front of you and not help them
out that's that's just not in your
[ __ ] blood you know I think to a
certain extent it just became really
detrimental to you yeah because you were
giving up so much of yourself and not
checking up on yourself
that you thought that okay well I got
all these people on my back like not in
that type of way but that you're
carrying their weight yeah
and if you left them out you feel like a
[ __ ] like a Chauncy ass [ __ ]
you know yeah that's the thing man is I
don't like to I don't like to give up on
people that I care about
yeah right and I felt that you know
leaving or breaking up or whatever I
thought that was failing on on the
relationship in us yeah but I'm super
thankful that she brought it up and she
realized it and she saw that it was
inevitable like it was just a downward
spiral because I think the my just my
personality is I don't give up when I
just go I just go and
till it works yeah and sometimes that's
a stupid way to approach life yeah
because you don't you don't have an
endgame you don't know when when to say
okay this isn't working like I don't
like to admit to it because to me that's
failure I just want to keep fighting
until it wins and then after that I was
like that's exactly when my buddy from
Vietnam Danny though he was like hey man
like I went through a similar situation
and he's like come to Vietnam and be
like I've been trying to get you to come
here in the last 10 years I made a life
for myself that he's like I have no
friends out here please somebody speak
English it's he was one of the original
members of JK and he helped us like
build a film oh that's like he's the one
who didn't yes right yeah man so it was
like a such a good story because man
there's so much more we can talk about
but like it's like he had to do what he
had to do and I think he's still [ __ ]
guilty about this cuz the for the first
four days I was there he would not shut
the [ __ ] up about it and I was like
Danny I accept your decision it's been
15 [ __ ] years bro like like move on
and he's like nah bro you don't
understand I feel bad so basically he
was apologizing for the first four
[ __ ] days that he abandoned us so we
did pretty well first I just kept making
reasons why he had to move to Vietnam
and and almost like Danny like I think
you're hurt more than I am
yeah cuz he's like yeah he's like at the
time you know like I felt like I was
leaving you guys not not I'm not like
that like I just you know I just like I
just had dreams of being a director I'm
like we accept it yeah we moved on you
know like in and so then I realized that
I just gotta let him talk and every day
he would bring you said I get rid of
that guilt he had so much guilt and
that's when I realized that this is a
really true friend that I did not
appreciate yeah because I didn't realize
how much it hurt him that he had to
leave JK and create a life for himself
and he's doing really [ __ ] well out
there yeah he did a feature film he's
doing another one this April and he's
working with this huge pop star out
there named like Sun ton or some [ __ ]
like that I forgot his name but he ya
dude like he's doing great and I'm just
like hella proud of them but the
amount of guilt that he was carrying and
he's like I just wanted you guys you and
Bart to come to Vietnam and us and you
see like what it was all worth it then I
left
JK to do this and I'm like man it
doesn't even matter do this like hey
Danny is like I haven't thought about
you once did you left I was like I only
thought about you now that you hit me up
other than that I little if you died I
would have never known yeah but he was
in it he was in a toxic relationship -
hmm and then well his ended up pretty
bad in a way we're like he got cheated
on and all that stuff and I was like
yeah that's rough man but he's like you
she's like I know that I know the right
thing that you need and then he brought
me out and he man this guy he set
everything up for me I didn't have to
[ __ ] think that his apology tour dude
dude he [ __ ] I literally walked in he
was my tour guide he was my he set up
all the meals everything like he thought
of everything ahead and I'm so [ __ ]
thankful because that was the first time
when I was able to just take a ride in
someone's back seat because I'm always
in control yeah for something you know
like whenever I'm vacationing or
whatever it's like someone's looking at
me hey what are we gonna do next what
are gonna do that can you choose what
the food or whatever you're like what do
you think what do you think people have
to look at me and and I have to make a
decision and I didn't realize like I
wanted to be taken care of from time to
time that's what a vacation was vacation
was just always us try to plant [ __ ] out
you know yeah [ __ ] man I don't even want
to do that sometimes I just want it like
I've been on set for two weeks I've been
on set for two weeks right when I got
back I just started unpacking on
cleaning setting up this office so it's
like [ __ ] we can't get a break right